I think so many people are willing to
turn their back on the president does he
have a loyalty issue well I do think I
mean we're talking about a limited
number of individuals right we're
talking about a handful of folks
probably that have left and written the
kinds of books that you're talking about
cliff Sims was one that you know I've
worked you know I wouldn't say alongside
him but I worked near him from time to
time you know he was a mid-level staffer
who kind of has glorified his role and
painted a picture that I don't think
reflects the white house that I saw and
I don't think he was in a lot of the
meetings and a lot of the things that he
kind of depicts in the book I mean they
just kind of strains credulity if you
read it and there are other examples
that that kind of exists you know I
can't explain what goes through the head
of a staff member who is gonna go out
and say all these negative things about
the place you work at if that's the case
I think it's a privilege to work in the
White House
you should leave and nothing compares to
the pressures to the sustained kind of
scrutiny and the challenges that people
face in a White House you know there
you're gonna break some eggs there's
gonna be you know a shouting match here
and there did you witness some of those
shouting matches as you say yeah there
been there been quite a few I mean you
know people get passionate about policy
about issues about personnel decisions
and you can get hot sometimes it is a
very dangerous time for journalists so
you concerned the divisive rhetoric
could ultimately risk journalists lives
well I mean that's I think there can
always be a concern you know I I don't
pretend to fully grasp all the other
risks associated with being a journalist
in parts of the world that don't afford
the kinds of protections that we have in
the United States and I think in in
general it's always good to see the
temperature turn down a little bit I
mean my boss my former boss Sarah
Sanders like she can't go you know out
in Washington DC without being accosted
by somebody you know I mean like that's
a terrible situation
she has three young children I you know
my heart goes out to
and I don't think there's a lot of like
sympathy or people concerned about her
welfare I think she's the first White
House press secretary that's been
required to have Secret Service
protection in the history of the country
so that goes to tell you that I think
that in general the the heat in the
situation with some of the rhetoric is a
little too high and I think that's
unfortunate
we also live in a free country and so I
think there are actions that obviously
cross the line and you know those have
to be dealt with when they happen you
worked at the RNC
you have a lot of experience in
opposition research you were reported to
have described the president at one
point as a deplorable have you changed
your mind yeah I have and I I think I
think some of that stuff was taken a
little bit out of context in the height
of a in a height of a you know bad news
cycle you know a lot of us were kind of
taken aback by the president's campaign
by a lot of things that he was doing and
I you know he won me over he won a lot
of Republicans over over the course of
that primary and you know I'm very proud
of the the time that I've served in this
White House some of the big things that
were able to do on tax reform on you
know the Supreme Court on regulatory
issues I mean his whole bevy of things
that we've worked on that I'm very proud
of so anything I may have said you know
and the kind of the heat of the moment
years ago you know I probably I probably
want to take a have a few take backs you
know you were working for a president
who can often announce policy by tweets
how is that managing messaging when you
don't necessarily know what's coming
well I think you know the president kind
of used social media in a way that is
unprecedented may never be used that way
again right I mean he was making news on
daily basis more often than not the
staff and the team was aware to a large
degree about where things were going but
I mean yeah at times it caught us a
little bit off guard and we kind of had
to kind of roll with it and that's just
sort of the nature of this White House
this president everybody just kind of
you know rolls with the fact that
he can make decisions that kind of any
point that that he deems fit any
particular moments that stick in your
mind that took me by surprise they were
quite a few is there quite a concerted
effort to try and find these strategic
phrases whether it's radical Democrats
or its enemy of the people well I would
say in general the president is you know
kind of a branding genius on his own we
saw that throughout the campaign framing
some of his political opponents in ways
that were very effective and I think
quite cutting at times so I think you
know I think he'll take input but he
seems to be able to figure those things
out pretty well himself you oversaw the
communications behind Brett Cavanaugh's
nomination of course later appointed
Supreme Court justice that was a big
success for the president were there
times during the Brett Kavanaugh
nomination process when you were worried
that actually the tide might be turning
against him well I mean I've been enough
I've been in enough situations to
understand that sometimes when it looks
bleak it's usually not as bad as it
looks as it does when it looks good it's
usually not as good as it looks right
but yeah I mean I think that any casual
observer had to look at the situation at
times and be concerned you know one of
the things that I found to be very
reassuring and I've been in probably
about now about four or five really
contentious confirmation battles or
personnel matters of this sort is the
people that had known Brett Kavanaugh
for years had stood by him from
different parts of his life whether you
know his time and executive service or
the clerk's that worked with him or
people that went to high school with him
none of them ever flinched when to
asking to be character witnesses when I
mean we're talking about hundreds of
people here I've never seen that before
we're now at the point of the State of
the Union why do you think he still
wants to take part in what is really
conventional stagecraft for a president
well I think that it is conventional but
they're also thinking
is a unique thing to the presidency that
kind of placed as advantage right he'll
have a hour maybe hour and a half long
you know prime time fixated audience
that is not going to be taking in his
message through the filter of the media
or cable news or kind of the chatter in
class he gets to talk directly to the to
the country and he can make his case in
a way that that only he is is kind of
empowered to make it looking back is
there anything that you regret that you
would have done differently or you
thought could have been managed better I
mean probably dozens you know I'll let
that I'll let that go to the people that
read my emails you know ten years from
what they're when they're released by
the presidential records folks I think
look the the pace and speed of press
coverage today pace and speed with which
we have to react to these issues forces
us to make lots of snap second decisions
and I think there's there's plenty that
you could have done a better job we do
the best job we can with the information
we have and then kind of have to move on